variety power of women I know there's a
lot of incredible women in your life who
is the one who pushes you and motivates
you to be better
oh that's such a hard question I know
that my daughter is not a woman yet
Cairo
but she pushes me to be better she's
only four years old but I'm a strong
believer that yes I'm a strong believer
that children learn through observation
she's going to learn and see how I
navigate through this world
and so she motivates me to make the
right decisions no matter what those
decisions are whether they're in
relationships whether they're with your
job your career
um she really does she's an extension of
who I am
she really really is and I tell you
nothing made me happier than seeing you
and your twin sister Tamara galavanting
around Italy yes because in the
beginning of the pandemic the two of you
told me we didn't have we didn't see
each other and it was devastating
uh I still haven't seen her physically
um no I I I after six months no have you
had your opportunity to have your family
reunion with Tamara yet so yes I have
you get to go to Italy oh my God a dream
vacation I mean it was all about the ass
what is the uh the aspiral uh or else
overall Sprints oh my gosh we had so
many of those drinks
and we were just I one of my favorite
memories of us just walking down you
know because there's a lot of like
Cobblestone you know in Italy
just walking down the streets and just
having a great time and drinking our
Spritz just sharing stories and then not
only that because we had gone to Italy
when we were in college together so to
be in Italy with again with our children
and our husbands it was just so amazing
and surreal and just so wonderful oh my
gosh you know I I love that you got to
spend that time together in Italy
because I know it must be difficult you
live in LA Tamara's in Napa how are you
guys doing with that adjustment living
in such Faraway cities you know what we
definitely prioritize our time together
I was just on the phone with her today
actually and we're talking about doing a
trip to Disneyland for Halloween
um together with the kids so they can
all dress up in costumes and all of that
good stuff I'm a True Believer in just
creating memories you know what I mean
memories with family it's it means
everything to us and our family so and
then also we're going to be going down
to Napa for uh Thanksgiving so yes yes
and so just to spend a lot of time with
them next month marks the the premiere
episode of the final season of Family
Reunion
[Applause]
October 27th you guys only on Netflix
about it coming to an end
I feel sad it has been a great show and
we I mean we've had three seasons which
has been amazing
um I still talked to Loretta Devine
almost every other day I'm constantly
texting her I feel so blessed to be able
to
you know continue to be doing what I
love to do which is acting and also um
four camera comedy I feel like it's it's
it's become kind of rare like meaning
just 30 minute four camera comedy it's
usually right
um I feel like it's more about like the
hour you know dramedies
um so to still be a part of that genre
of Television I just feel so honored and
and I feel you know grateful so you seem
to really love that format I do what is
next do you want to stay with that
format of show I mean I feel like you'd
be a great talk show host
so many people have told me that it runs
in the family you have to make sure that
you do your research I mean who knows
that could be the next thing you know I
have a talk show called Tia
um no but I you know what I actually I
wanna I love comedy so yeah I I do I
want to stick to a sitcom I'm not
opposed to the one-hour dramedies so
we'll see if if that happens
um but I'm all about just like family
entertainment comedy I've been doing it
for years and and it's you know I have a
lot of fun doing it have you read
Tamara's Memoir you know what I have not
yet
I know I know I'm so proud of her do you
think you know everything in there or do
you think there's going to be some
surprises and some secrets I'm her twin
we shared the womb we'll make up I mean
come on I know everything about her and
she knows everything about me so is it
is it your turn to put out a memoir you
know what I was thinking about this I
think in the next few years maybe like
you have a lot of stories I do I can't I
do I'm a little mysterious like I feel
like my my yeah I feel like I do have a
lot to say it's just when am I gonna say
it
foreign